I have been married people say to me I
talked about this is my special but it's
true people say to me you know 40 years
to the same woman and I always say this
I got I'll be honest with you when I
married
Terri she was like she wanted a party
all the time and have sex all the time
this is not the same woman all right
[ __ ] same name and every why would you
woo when I'm talking about sex with my
wife please that makes me uncomfortable
why is he very invested in the notion of
head-on sex with your wife yeah my
wife's a tough cookie you want I'm
telling you she's mad at me she gets mad
is it another thing I talked about the
special but it's true you know what she
got mad at me about this is just
marriage takeaway she got mad at me for
I'm trying to say this television we're
peeing in the shower does it anybody
here pee in the shower everyone but why
would you not well that's the point but
she said it's not that I peed in the
shower is she this is absolutely true
she said it's because I don't follow her
rule she made a rule this is the rule in
our house she goes Howie if you are
going to this is what she said how if
you're going to pee in the shower you
have to be taking a shower and I said
[Applause]
good reason my god I know how you put up
with it I don't know how you do it I
mean the point is she was so I'm here
running water I love you're explaining
it are you explaining it yeah we put
people put people in the audience to
explain what's happened what did you say
after I talked about peeing what did you
just say no he said no no no no because
she said could you do that to me
[Applause]